hallo leute ich es wieder einmal waren
und willkommen zu meinem nächsten 33
ich weiß ihr seid wahrscheinlich alle
fast vor aufregung gestorben aber es
geht jetzt weiter rohwaren wird also
waren wir bis weihnachten bis
weihnachten ist es nicht mehr weit
ohne witz mit lichterketten diese
weihnachtsstimmung angefangen und wenn
wir auf cnet oder instagram volk der
weiß was ich meine
ich habe die stelle gefunden und jetzt
kann es weitergehen das letzte mal hat
mit dem dreißigsten fünften und heute
haben wir den 31.05 2015 es ist nicht so
wie du denkst wie es aussieht
nein nein ich bin schuld hervor
das ist mein leben
oh mein gott da steht heimat haiti nach
dem mathe förder sind ich und sophie
döner essen gegangen dann zur bücherei
zum internet da haben wir marvin dort
getroffen
na klar früher noch in die bücherei
gegangen im internet zu kriegen
als mir und sophie das geld ausgegangen
ist da sind wir zu marvin gefahren okay
ich fang an cool zu werden man merkt
sich langsam im internet schreibe weil
ich jetzt nicht mehr wir mit wie er
schreibe sondern wie vanessa richtig
cool da sind wir zu knuddels ryan und
ich habe hausaufgaben gemacht war
vanessa erster sechster 2005 alter ich
war richtig regelmäßig also das war
meine höchstzeit glaube da alles klar
ich bin heute wieder mit sophie zu
machen gefahren wir haben ihn eis
mitgebracht als wenn man die ganzen
abends internet schnorr dann bringt man
wenigstens ein ice mit torben war auch
da haben wir haben alle singstar
gespielt und smackdown u sing star
smackdown die beste kombination um das
herz einer frau zu europa am freitag
gehe ich und sophie wieder dorthin aber
ich bin nicht in marvin er ist aber noch
in milch bei bei vanessa pudel
ja mein knuddels name oder 13 pudel 13
er klar ich hier 13
ich glaube ich wollte pudel schreiben
was du mont pudel zu schreiben ist
eigentlich ziemlich kacke von mir ich
gehe zu machen obwohl ich weiß dass er
mich ist nur um singstar und smackdown
spielen zu können und bei knuddels
rumzuhängen zweiter sechser 2005 ich
raste aus so regelmäßig bin jetzt schon
richtig gut mit marvin befreundet aber
er denkt immer noch dass er eine chance
bei mir ja vanessa wir haben es
verstanden man steht noch auf dich du
nicht auf ihn oder du bist hier nicht
sicher und kann auch ganz vielleicht
sein
er ist ja ziemlich süß und ich und
seinem planen schon viel für sophies
geburtstag bei baywa dritter sechster
2005 hallo du wirst es nicht glauben ich
bin wieder mit marvin zusammen oh mein
gott nein ich werde es nicht glauben
aber er weiß es noch nicht was du wirst
es nicht glauben ich bin wieder mit
marvin zusammen aber er weiß es noch
nicht
wie kann ich mit maren zusammen sein
wenn es noch nicht weiß ich kann ihnen
leider nicht erreichen warum bist du der
mitte zusammen
es hat heute ziemlich neu gewittert
sophie bei es ist schon
ich kann ihnen leider nicht erreichen es
hat heute ziemlich gewittert so viel
weiß es schon einmal gut als irgendwann
ist die grenze erreicht und das ist
schon passiert und ich gehe immer wieder
über diese grenze ich will ihn mal
küssen ja wenn du mit mann zusammen ist
dann
ob sie noch küssen wollen oder umarmen
ich freue mich voll auf sophies
geburtstag bei vanessa warum bin ich
wieder mitmachen zusammen warum weiß er
das nicht wie ist so etwas möglich
kannst denn so ist eine gute wenn auch
wie steht und ich mich dazu entscheide
mit ihm zusammen kommen zu wollen dann
ist die antwort ja auch klar denn dann
könnte ich schon sagen deswegen aber
nein solange er ist nicht weiß ist man
nicht zusammen ich bin mit brad pitt
zusammen denn ich habe heute von ihm
geträumt ich habe tatsächlich heute
nachdem brad pitt geträumt und jetzt
wenn ich mit ihm zusammen eine seite die
sich noch vierter sechster 2005 hey du
ich bin wieder mit maren zusammen
irgendwie ist das auch komisch wie er
sich verhält verhält er schreibt immer
you und so ich weiß doch dass er mich
liebt das brauche mir nicht immer sagen
bei angriff ist haseloff wie ist so
eingeschnappt beim 1
wie kommt marvin darauf mir ich liebe
dich zu schreiben wenn wir zusammen sind
ist er denn bescheuert ok eine sache
muss ich noch klarstellen marvin wenn du
das siehst es tut mir leid
leicht hatte ich eine krankheit die man
noch nicht erkannt hat aber es tut mir
wirklich leid okay leute ich muss einen
cliffhanger unterlassen damit ich auch
sicher bin dass jedes nächste mal
einschaltet wie sie den anfang von der
nächsten seite okay seid gespannt
sechster sechster 2005 hallo ich habe
ein was ich habe einen so süßen jungen
kennengelernt er heißt tim wenn das
nicht mal der allerbeste cliffhanger
aller zeiten ist leipzig mit marvin
zusammen und wer ist eigentlich dieser
typ
das und mehr erfahren sie in der
nächsten folge germany
ich liebe es ja wie ich früher setzte
gebildet habe zwei wichtige
informationen einfach zusammen klatschen
und dazwischen perfekt ich habe die
suppe gekocht und ich möchte mit dir
schluss machen
super